and we're following breaking news from
Syria in a major US policy shift this
morning American troops are pulling back
to make way for turkeys planned invasion
a part of northern Syria video out this
morning shows American forces leaving an
area along Turkey's border Turkey is
targeting us back Kurdish fighters that
have been key American allies in the
fight against Isis the abrupt change
follows a phone call last night between
President Trump and Turkey's president
how the Williams has reported
extensively throughout the region
probably the big question of all great
to have you at the table you second of
all what is this mean for the fight
against Isis yeah what it means is that
America's most important ally on the
ground in the fight against Isis looks
like it's about to get involved in an
armed conflict with Turkey which is an
American NATO ally so that sounds really
bad right off the bat I'm mr.
complicated part of the world so just
for some background when America decided
it wanted to fight Isis in Syria it went
looking for a partner and the only
people who were ready willing and able
to fight against Isis with a Syrian
democratic forces or SDF but from the
beginning of that partnership turkeys
been saying America you shouldn't be
doing business with these guys because
we regard them as terrorists the threat
now is that the SDF we spoke to them
this morning they said we are going to
fight turkey but the bigger risk also is
that the SDF says to America we feel
betrayed you've let us down why should
we do your fighting America against Isis
we're going to look after our interests
not yours well we all know it's been
complicated listen that even the
administration was divided on whether to
withdraw their troops we remember former
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis resigned
over it so what can you tell us about
how the president reached reached this
decision so I don't know the
nitty-gritty of this decision what I can
say is that Turkey has been pushing the
u.s. really hard on this for months
threatening to invade Syria as you say
this is really contentious within this
current administration back in December
President Trump said he was going to
withdraw all US troops from Syria and
the former Secretary of Defense resigned
over that that decision was later
watered down so that US troops went from
two-and-a-half thousand to a thousand
troops in this part of Syria what I can
tell you is that when I was in Syria
about two weeks ago I interviewed the
head of the SDF general Muslim kobani
and he told me
that when the US military told him that
they would be withdrawing the office is
who he deals with said we don't agree
with this we don't think it's a good
decision you know but we don't have any
choice here it's complicated and to echo
Tony good to have you at the table safe
and sound please be careful thank you
Holly Williams